Speaker 1: All right, so we're going to start
today with something a little different will
will be kind of taking a tour or having
a lesson in reactionary fear mongering
and how people can get sort of sucked into
reactionary thinking and these reactionary ideas.
And we're going to start today. We
actually have two clips that we're
going to look at two different segments.
In the first clip, we're going to look at a
piece of an interview that right wing host Glenn
Beck recently did with a guy named James Lindsay.
And I don't want to say too much about the clip
to start with, other than you really can identify
serious analogies to the sort of febrile screeds
of authoritarians and fascists over the history
of the 20th century. There's a lot of Mussolini
in what I'm going to play for you here, and what
you were going to see are essentially unfounded
conspiracy theories presented in a particular way
to make you afraid and to make you want to say,
we have to stop this and the way to stop this
is by discriminating against others, taking away
the rights of others, etc. And you're going to
see Glenn Beck conducting the interview
here. James Lindsay is being interviewed,
and let's just jump right in, and then we're going
to talk about a lot of different things here.
Speaker 2: They know that I have this
really bizarre belief not to get too
theoretical out of that. I don't believe that
we ever actually had a marketplace of ideas.
I don't think it actually arrived. I think we
ended up getting an aristocracy of ideas through
these expert class, whether it's a big government,
whether it's, you know, university progressive
era. Yeah, I think that was the first part.
Speaker 1: Here is even the information you
are given. It's all controlled by elites,
individuals and it's not true. And they want
to apply this to COVID right now, but they want to
apply it to a lot of other things. And of course,
there's always a kernel of truth, which is,
well, we should all think about how we came
to believe the things we believe. We should
think critically. But these are the very people
who write off that type of education, critical
thinking, epistemology, philosophy, media literacy
as left wing indoctrination. So they're telling
you you've been tricked. But they also don't want
you to have the tools to avoid being tricked
Speaker 2: at an aristocracy of ideas. And
what happened is that the internet has unleashed
the flame of the Enlightenment a second time.
Speaker 1: And of course, again, he's right
that the internet has made it difficult for
people to figure out what's real and what's
not. But the disinformation that is being
spread on the internet in the COVID era is
disproportionately right nonsense. There's
also left wing nonsense on the internet
as well. And we've talked about, you know,
natural news and anti-vax movements that predate
COVID, which which did have elements on the left.
But they're they're describing what they've done.
Speaker 2: I'm telling you, these people are
frauds and they're criminals and they're
they're jokes and it's it's coming for them.
They are going to lose all of their power. They're
going to be exposed for crimes, the likes of which
we've never seen in human history that you, you
are 100 percent right. This is this, I believe,
is the biggest crime in all of human history.
Speaker 1: And of course, what are they talking
about, right? They are stimulating fear. It's not
even really clear. Like, what are you saying is
the crime that people post stuff to the internet
that we don't think is true? Like, what exactly
are you talking about? And this is typical.
They use grandiose language. Trump does it, too.
It's the it's the biggest political crime we've
ever seen, and it's not super clear what it is,
but you see them being alarmist
and it makes others alarmist.
Speaker 2: Five of the biggest crimes in human
history mixed in one. Yeah. And it when it when
it when it all hits. If they don't have us
all in cages, right? They're in trouble.
They're in a lot of trouble. They're in a lot.
Speaker 1: Now that's again, it's it's going to
get much worse and they might enslave us and on
and up. But but what are they even talking about?
Speaker 2: And if they do have us all in
cages, we're in a lot of trouble because that,
you know, I saw this. I don't know if you
saw this clip from the World Economic Forum,
one of the elite said, you know, we did
this study. And the good news is the elites
trust the other elites more than ever
before. Yeah, but the others don't trust us
anywhere on Earth. Yeah, you better have a
rock solid prison everywhere. Yeah, because
there will be a revolution. Yeah.
Speaker 1: What on earth is he talking about?
And I really want to encourage everybody to read
the article. Called The Reactionary Trap by Seth
Moskowitz, we're going to have Seth on the show in
maybe in April to talk about it. He outlines just
Google. Seth Moskowitz, the reactionary trapper,
also going to link to it on the YouTube channel.
He explains exactly how people fall into this
reactionary type of thinking, and he specifically
talks about James Lindsay in the article.
Actually, actually. And when we say reactionary,
what we're talking about is someone with extreme
opposition to dramatic social or political change.
And of course, sometimes there's reasons to
oppose dramatic social or political change.
But what distinguishes reactionaries, as
Seth writes in the article, is number one,
they become so preoccupied with who or what
they are against that the foundation of their
own politics throws out all reason and first
principles. And we've seen this now for years.
And as I've told you before, you have these right
wingers who state certain principles. And as soon
as the principles conflict with what the outcomes
are or are inconvenient to the outcomes they want,
they abandoned their principles. We've seen
this when it comes to business regulation.
We've seen this with my body, my choice, all of
these different things. They have principles they
state are their principles. And as soon as those
principles would go counter to what they want
as the preconceived, predetermined outcome, then
they abandon the principles. So that's check. And
then number two reactionaries vastly inflate the
threat of whatever they oppose. They, you know,
we might just be against something for
some kind of, you know, sensible reason.
And we just don't like it. But nothing
catastrophic is going to happen. But no,
they have to inflate the threat and say
it will be a catastrophe if X happens.
And what that does is it drives disproportionate
responses. If you're told, Oh yeah, I mean,
you know, if schools require a COVID vaccine,
next thing you know, we'll all be in cages. That
drives a disproportionate response when it's like,
actually, there have been vaccine requirements for
100 years and it doesn't escalate. There's no
slippery slope and we'll talk about that next.
And there's a lot of we've seen a lot of that in
history, like the anti-communist movement of the
20th century. Remember? I'm not a socialist, I'm
not a communist, but I accurately see that there
was no threat right when we go to the McCarthy
hearings, et cetera. It's threat inflation. This
is going to end everything. It's going to end
life as we know it. And really a masterclass in
fascistic authoritarian fear mongering here from
Glenn Beck and James Lindsay. And we've got a
similar thing in the next segment when it comes
to Dave Rubin. So let's talk about that next.